Okay, but that's not true. [music] You actually would sit her
down with a whiteboard and go over everything to convince her
that she was wrong. Why can't this guy just be like, "Yo, this
is pretty crazy stuff if this is true, but like uh we'll wait
and see. I don't believe Mskiss because Misks are and that's
it." >> Oh, if if these texts exist and are preserved,
he's cooked. He's like totally cooked. That's what got him. That's
totally what got him right there. Oh, I missed this when I was
reading through. That's 100% what cooked him.
>> I might go check out this miskip bit. This this part
of the VOD where he goes over these documents cuz honestly if
he's going to put them up publicly, it's like it's already like
pretty wide and I don't think there's like a particular reason
not to go over it. It's like a little more personal and I didn't
want to be the first one to cover it. But if he's going to cover
it, I might as well
go give it a listen because it does give a little more coloring.
It it definitely doesn't show techone in a favorable light at
all.
Okay, I'm pretty sure we're safe here with uh with this part
of it. We'll we'll take a look. We're going to pull it up. Let's
take a look. The names of officials aren't censored. Wait, what
are you talking about? Are you talking about something to do
with the previous thing? The Pisco thing? Possibly.
XQC only beating out IRI by 2K up votes. It is goofy, man. It
is goofy. >> Name is going to be blurred out as well as
her address. John Roberts's name is going to be blurred out as
or not going to be blurred out as his address will and phone
number. So will Pink Chu's phone number and her address. Okay,
so just want to make that very clear that I, you know, despite
me having a vendetta and being petty towards Techone, if I really
wanted to be that petty and if I >> Okay, this is Msk going
over
the Techone documents. Uh, reviewing Msk covering Teone Docs
live. Uh, no, not live.
Teone. Okay. All right. Let's check it out. Let's check it out.
>> I really want didn't want to be objective. I would just
leave up his phone number. I would leave up his address and I
would let you guys do anything you want. I'm not I'm not doing
that. Uh I'm not going to do that. Even though I'm on kick and
I could do whatever the I want here. I'm not doing that. I removed
all this.
>> I'm pretty sure you can't just openly dox people on
kick. I'm pretty sure you can get [__] up for that.
Okay. Just
don't think that you can do that. That's not something I paid
someone to go through this so they went through it.
>> that's it. Uh,
>> isn't this just public? >> Every other person
in the document is not censored. Yeah, but you don't really need
to like there's no particular reason to censor the lawyers to
be honest with you. >> There's like really only it's like
basically Pinky that needs her that you would want her name censored.
And like if if Te's name was unknown, I would say you should
censor Tech Tone's name. Like if Teone didn't use his name on
the internet everywhere,
then I would say you should censor his name as well. >> It
is public, but you got to think of it this way. the streamers
who are reacting to this content, in my opinion, have a a service
that they must do to not make sure they docked. It's the same
thing for content creators. You don't go into someone's room
and say, "Hey, dude, your address is 32 Wayne, you know, street."
You don't do that because you know that the viewers will find
it. The thing is, uh, but they any viewer can find where a streamer
lives, but you don't want to give them that opportunity,
>> right? So, I'm not going to do that. Even though I hate
Tech Tone, I'm not going to do that. Um, did I just leave your
address? I'm >> If it's If it's like a moral requirement
that you don't dox people, then you shouldn't also say that it's
like a moral good you're doing by doxing them. But, you know,
we just keep going. >> You don't do that as a streamer.
You don't do that in any way. Uh, I think streamers have an opportunity
to do not stuff. Doxing [snorts] is pretty serious, especially
when you're having something like this because people are going
to be heated whether they're on Pinchu side or Tech Tones and
that can lead to bad things. Um, so it's it's
>> Okay. This is John Robertson. Travis County is in Texas
chat. It's where we live. This is for Travis County. Um, and
she is the applicant. John Robertson is the respondent. So, let's
go through this. Okay. So, the application for the protective
order to the honorable judge of said court. The application is
the Judge County Attorney's Office by and through her attorneys
Hillary Riley uh which is I guess her uh lawyer is making this
application for protective order on behalf of PinkJu for the
protection of and in best interest of persons alleged to be victims
of family violence, sexual assault, and or stalking. Okay, I'm
probably going to skip I might be able to skip through a decent
amount of this cuz I don't think it actually matters all that
much
that uh like this is all boiler plate, right? This >> application
request the honorable court to issue after seven lawyer the same
appearance family. Notice how blank and the unavailability of
documentation or other criminal cases. the respondant has been
convicted of or placed on the Texas L6 penal code for techone
facts alleged by this reference in indecent assault trafficking
and or stalking if a temporary exparte protective order is not
granted. Applicant therefore requests that the court immediately
and without hearing issue a temporary exart. >> So this
is because they did they got a um temporary exparte. They're
saying that they're coming in and they're saying basically without
any hearing at all we want you to grant this. Now, I do believe
these things will be granted. So, this is the thing where Teone's
going to try to play a game. Okay, Tone's going to play this
game and other people are going to play this game where they're
going to say, "Well, the temporary order was immediately granted
and you don't need that much proof for the temporary order."
That might be true that it's possible that Texas might lean towards,
hey, we should grant temporary orders fast and then we do a hearing
to see if a if a if a non-exparte so exparte means Tees not even
represented. Tectone doesn't get to represent his own rights.
Tect's rights are going to be curbed based on this hearing. So
it is an emergency hearing. It's like an emergency thing, right?
So with the further hearing that happened, the hearing that we
just had on the 23rd, that is not the case. Okay? That wasn't
something exparte. That was both sides bring your evidence and
then we'll make a decision. Both sides brought their evidence
and then they made a decision. Okay? So, it is not the same thing.
So, I saw some I think it's the um I think it's the Mama Octa
Mama OA or whatever that stupid octopus person. They said, "Oh,
well, they just grant these." I don't think they just grant the
long form versions of these. I don't think that's how that goes.
I think they grant the temporary version because you say, "Hey,
this happened and they don't want you to get they don't want
you to get beat up, right?" So they grant the temporary one and
they say, "Okay, we're scheduling a hearing because we can't
just take this person's rights away indefinitely."
Yeah. Obviously. >> Parte protection order prohibiting
respondent from the following acts until a hearing can be held.
After notice and hearing, applicant requests that the court enter
a protective order effective for a period of time allowed under
Texas Family Code section 85.025
and/or Texas Code of Criminal Procedure C chapter 7B007.
So basically chat, they are trying to get a protective order
before the court even happens because they are afraid >> I'm
going to close Misk's chat. Jesus, I don't think I'd have that
on Twitch. Yo yo yo yo
yo. Uh, wait, we're not on Twitch. Okay, somebody in Misk's chat,
I think they're talking about Lucari's
ex-girlfriend,
and somebody just said like, "Oh, who cares what she says? She's
a mud shark." >> Jesus, man. Techone is going to stalk
and or continue to uh act in violence, assault, indeent assault,
trafficking, and or stalking.
>> Um, this is why Tech didn't stream, by the way, chat.
It's because this happened. This got uh approved and Tech can't
shut the [__] up about uh Pinkchu, so he stopped
streaming probably by his lawyers telling him, "Hey, you should
shut the [__] up and stop streaming because you don't
know how to stop. you have caused yourself so much [__]
>> or I mean
I didn't see in the documents this is what one of the things
I read these documents for was I was looking for any evidence
that they basically came and said hey this guy is still talking
about it this guy is still like putting himself in trouble right
but it does seem possible that in the most recent thing maybe
that was a part of their evidence is like hey this guy wasn't
supposed to do anything here's how this guy talks about me when
he's like not being told by his lawyers to not talk about me.
Here's what he says. Here's the kind of he does. >> All
right.
Committing acts of a family violence, sexual assault, indecent
assault, trafficking, or stalking against the applicant or any
member of the applicant's family or household, including acts
intended to result in physical harm, bodily injury, assault of
assault, or threats reasonably placing a person in fear of p
physical harm, bodily injury, assault or assault, and not to
use any force that would cause injury to the applicant. B. communicating
in a threatening or harassing manner with the applicant or any
member of the applicant's family or household. C. communicating
a threat or attempting to communicate a threat probably therefore
by stream through any person or any person who is listed in the
application as a person seeking protection or a member of the
applicant's household >> 200 yard >> upon finding
that good >> I think we're being told as well since signal
might have been saying that misk did get permission to read these
documents right that he was permitted he was allowed >> cause
exist prohibit respondent from communicating with applicant or
any member of applicant's household or family in any manner whatsoever
except through an attorney. E going within 200 yards of the applicant,
applicant's residency, applicant's place of work, applicant's
children, applicant's children's schools or child care facilities,
or any locations where he/e knows the applicant, applicant's
children, or any person listed as seeking protection to be except
as necessary for court proceedings or to carry out visitation
as set out by the court order.
F damaging, transferring, encumbering or otherwise disposing
of any property mutually owed or leased by applicant and respondent
except in the normal course of business.
So that would be anything that they had during the interesting
also probably and if I >> because we do hear them. It it
sounds like there's no particular legal authority that's blocking
>> if you guess >> this guy from talking about it,
right? It seems like there's no particular legal authority that's
saying sorry that's blocking Teone from from ever referencing
the the case or the protective order.
It seems like his lawyers have probably said, "Hey, we don't
believe you'll do this without, you know, talking." He did say,
by the way, and I do think this would count as a threat. Could
we go back and find these? I think
I think Sophia sent these to me or something. Not to I maybe
shouldn't have even said that, but I think Sophia was the person
who
who linked me the time stamps for this. I wonder if this is in
my DMs with her or is it my old account? It must be my old account.
Funk.
But we watched the Teone. Do you remember the Techone stream
where he's like talking about how he is and how he is like going
to get this person back and like dude there was a bunch of [__]
where he would just talk about how like dude once this all passes
you have no idea it's going to be like it is going to be like
demon mode. You've awoken the demon. You're you're you're pulling
aggro right now. He was like he was just going off and I think
he's just talking about getting mad and yelling and like being
on his stream talking [__] >> but I think those
could eased
to removing or disabling any vehicle owned individually by the
applicant or jointly by the parties.
G tracking or monitoring personal property or motor vehicle in
this possession of applicant or a member of applicant's family
or household without the applicant's effective consent including
by and then it's listening them interfering with the exclusive
of a use apples of residence injuring harassing threatening or
harming applicants children so it's a lot about children harming
or causing harm to or removing from the possession of the applicant
or any member of the applicant's family or household and also
engaging in conduct directed specifically toward the applicant
or person who is a member of the applicant's family or household
including following the person that is reasonably likely to harass,
annoy, alarm, abuse, torment, or embarrass that person or stalking
the applicant as stalking is defined by section 42 072 Texas
Penal Code. The applicant further asked the court to suspend
the respondent's license to carry a handgun issued to respondent
under section
Government Code.
Prohibit the respondent from possessing a firearm. require.
>> By the way, the the
possession thing, I do believe that stops you from firing guns.
I think that prevents you from going to like gun ranges and firing
guns. I think that's like possess it. Like you literally can't
Well, I I think so.
I don't think that's just like possession as in like you own
>> respondent to transfer any firearms in his possession
immediately to an appropriate law enforcement agency and order
said agency to maintain the firearms in protective custody for
the duration of the protective order.
So that means that they are trying to get and they and Pikchu's
uh lawyers ask >> way just to be clear um regardless of
what the TTRO discussion is guys I just want to echo this one
more time regardless of what the discussion is around the initial
temporary order which this is okay regardless of what the discussion
is and I I would be willing to to acknowledge or accept that
a lower standard of evidence is required for this. That's not
the game anymore. That's not the ball game. It's not where the
balls moved. Okay, now it's no longer temporary. It's a it's
a permanent like timed restraining order, protective order in
this case. Okay, we're not in the temporary realm anymore. They
have weighed his rights against the idea that this person needs
to be protected and said for 10 years this person needs to be
protected. It's not it's not the low evidence, low bar of entry
like temporary restraining order anymore. So, we don't even have
to worry about that anymore. That's like what a lot of people
will say. They'll try to like Yeah. play this like sneaky little
game, this shell game, they can kick rocks. Okay, that's not
what's >> Tecton is such a threat that not only do we seek
that he has a restraining order, we want a protective order because
we believe Tecton is a threat and with him with a firearm that
he might go after uh Pink or any of Pink's friends or family.
Require respondent to transfer any firearms in his possession
immediately to an appropriate law enforcement. Require the respondent
to complete a battering inter.
It's so funny how closely this maps, if you remember, this is
where um this is where Tumad started to f fall off. Okay, they
basically told him, "Hey, you got to give us all your guns."
And then he was taking pictures of himself on stream with guns.
Okay. I hope Tek can avoid the same fall cuz he's not funny enough
to for us to ever forgive him. Okay. >> Intervention and
protective program and or another counseling program as specified
by the court. >> Damn. Property orders. The residence located
at blank is solely owned or leased by the applicant. Temporary
exparte order of finding based on the uh information in the attached
affidavit or declaration. The applicant asked the court to find
that there is a clear and present danger of family violence,
sexual assault or abuse, indecent assault, stalking, trafficking
or other harm to applicant and or a member of family or household
and issue a temporary exparte order immediately without bond
notice or hearing.
protect the act set forth better thing suspense to the clerk
of the court and
think it would be possible >> general relief >> to
get an interview with Pikachu
>> no I'm not going to I'm not going to bring Pikachu on
here because the truth is you guys might side with her some people
might side with her but the reality is that Pikachu does Only
Fans and has big and people are just going to use that cuz they're
uh Tech's disgusting right-wing community that he admits that
he farmed uh because Hassan
uh has a big head or some [__] Yeah, that community
is just going to say she's a only fans and that >> Pikachu
can join this stream, right? Yeah, we're very respectful of women
>> Don't listen to her and that she's a skank and uh she's
wrong and Techton's right and I hate when men get attacked. >> That's
all they're going to say. My name is Blank and I'm the resident
of Williamson County. I'm over 18 years of age, of sound mind,
and capable of making this decoration. This is going to be Pink
Chew. The facts stated herein and are within my personal knowledge
and are true and correct. I wish to file a protective order on
behalf of myself. I wish to file this order against John Robertson,
resident of Blank. And responded in this case, an incident occurred
in Blank County.
The relationship between the respondent and myself is previously
dated. We have lived together in the past from December 2022
to July 2024. We have zero children from our relationship. Obviously,
not because they never had. I have zero children from a previous
relationship. The respondent John Robertson committed the following
acts consider uh constituting and physical violence. Date of
violence incident was May 28th or 29th 2024. Location of incident
blank Austin, Texas. >> Three or
like >> three or four instances in here. uh usually chat
when someone assaults or abuses someone uh especially with assault.
Uh the girl would probably try to get out of the relationship
as fast as possible, not continuously date them and want to marry
them. Uh Pink Chu did that by May 28th or 29th this occurred
and then they broke up in >> that I he just
he's tried to farm his own situation. Don't do that. Don't I'm
They didn't break up until July and that's pretty clearly on
the record. So, no. No. That it's not what happens most of the
time. Miskf, you're just wrong. You're just wrong. Like,
he tries he's trying to say it's like the uh the Emiru thing,
right? That's what he's that's what he's doing there.
that's rough because Pikachu didn't break up with him right after
this. The May 25th, that's I believe that is uh 3 months before
they broke up. Is okay.
It's not the same. And it just don't even don't just don't, man.
Just don't dog. You don't have to. It's not >> uh Pink
Chu did that by May 28th or 29th. This occurred and then they
broke up in uh July. So it was just a three or four months and
then they finally broke
>> I do believe this is part of contemporaneous evidence
in this case. >> It's going to be interesting to see when
she got that done. Had responded been drinking or using drugs?
Yeah, I I do I I think this is a part of the contemporaneous
evidence that she had to go and get this done. And I'm guessing
she actually told her doctor like what happened in some way and
that the doctor was able I'm guessing this is a part of like
why they found it was >> no because he doesn't take his
schizophrenia medication. Uh what kind of weapons? None. If yes,
describe. I had to go to the doctor to get the filler dissolved.
So she had to go to the Wait. Yeah.
Did I require medical treatment? Yes. If Yes. has described I
had to go to the doctor to get the filler dissolved. Okay, so
she required medical treatment. She had to go to the doctor.
[snorts] The date of incident was 2024. The location of incident
was at this house. Um I was crying by the side of my bathtub
and John grabbed my head, shoved it towards his closed crotch,
and said that my crying turned him on. >> Damn. That's
uh not cool, dog.
Not cool, man. Not cool. Oh, they do go backwards IN TIME. NOT
COOL, DUDE. >> Did you call the police? No, but I later
reported this incident to the police on or around January 22nd,
2025.
So
I
um I would say the one thing that she definitely did wrong here
is she should have went to the police sooner. Um but she did
go at least to the police at one point. Uh I do find it interesting
when people say that someone assaulted them and they never go
to the police. Um but she did go to the police around January
22nd, 2025. So about 6 months later it seems like she went to
the police. Um
she did go. The date of incident was March 24th. Location of
incident blank. So she went to the police January. So yeah, it
was about say 8 months. John told me he wanted to perform a oral
sex on him. I had recently gotten a breast augmentation and was
told by a doctor not to lay on my stomach while I was recovering.
I told John that I didn't want to perform oral because of this.
When I first moved in with John in December 2022, he told me
that instead of paying rent, I'd have to perform oil on him whenever
he wanted. I felt like I had no other option but to comply around
February or March.
>> Bro, I can't believe like
he moved in in December.
Uh, I
I'm trying to think of like how psychotic you'd have to be to
like legitimately tell this to somebody and not be like joking
and not make it clear they're joking and not like give them basically
I feel like if I wanted to make this joke, I would feel like
I'd have to get like um what do you call it? I'd have to give
them like a bill of sale or something for rent. What is it? Like
a receipt. I'd need to give them like a receipt. Like you have
to pay me rent. I'm going to we're going to do receipts because
I I don't want this joke to be taken seriously.
You know what I mean?
you shouldn't even joke about it. But that's what I'm saying
is like you'd have to counter the implication somehow. Missy
is that that's what I'm saying. >> 2023 I told him I didn't
want to live by this agreement anymore and told him I'd pay for
his rent instead. However, after this he found other ways to
>> it was it sucking his was so unbearable that within
two months I was like bro I'll just pay you the money. Thousands
of dollars a year. Yeah. Thousands I'll pay thousands of dollars
not to have to suck this dick anymore. Okay. I'll pay thousands.
I'll pay thousands. Please get away to performing oral on him
when I didn't want to. For example, he remind me of items or
meals he bought for me and tell me that I owed it to him. If
I >> like, so I'm trying to do some Rosetta Stone here.
Okay. Like as in we are missing pieces of information. Hypothetically,
can we like fill in some of these pieces of information and figure
out what's going on? So Misk talked a little bit about like some
consensual non-consent stuff that happened possibly. Could that
be a part of like this dynamic where Te's like trying to say
you have to do this?
Like is that is that what's going on here?
I because the notes that we got the grammar was like really broken
and I don't know that we can understand exactly what's going
on. Although if we could talk to the Axian guy, it's possible
we could maybe figure it out.
um
like like maybe that's what he would argue is it was a part of
a dynamic that we both consented to and that we had like an understanding
but then it's like dude do you have like any documented conversations
about safe words about any of this stuff right
or were you just doing this like on the just on a wing and a
prayer I don't know cuz it seems like she's she's arguing now
she had no way to get out of it she didn't feel like she could
get out of it seems like she's making she's making the full-on
accusation that you were actually quite forcible about about
it at different times.
And I Yeah, I just don't know, man. I don't know what his arguments
what his argument could be here. I'm trying to think of like
cuz it doesn't seem like he really contests a lot of it. A lot
of like the the window dressing like that they
that this happened. >> I didn't comply immediately. He
repeatedly guilt trip me until I >> No, Accelerate. No,
that'll be the transcript from the court. it. After I moved out
in July 2024, I made a post on X about my experience as a victim
of sexual coercion, but I didn't did not identify a specific
perpetrator. John then threatened to post revenge porn of me
if I didn't take down the post. This made me very afraid because
I knew he had recorded me in the past. Oh.
Oh, if
if these texts exist and are preserved. Hey, he's cooked. He's
like totally cooked. That's what got him. That's totally what
got him right there. Oh, I missed this when I was reading through.
That's 100% what cooked him, right?
Cuz that you listen to, you know, the judge says you have to
delete all of this. I'm guessing that he explicitly made this
threat in text or otherwise
and was recorded. I'm guessing that he was actually recorded
or he just admitted to it. One of the two. Cuz like that's that
seals the whole thing for me is you make that threat immediately
she
she has every reason to be concerned and file for a protective
order where you can't like make any communications about her
to me >> past he also had consistently live streamed or
posted rants online claiming I am attempting to ruin his public
image on or around January 15th 2025 John made a post on ex saying
he would publicly
we've watched these we've watched these we've commented on these
we've we've talked about these I sent some of these to Shimu
So Shamu could peruse these,
bro. It's It's been >> text conversations, videos, etc.
between him and I online. I worked with an attorney to have John
served with a seasoned assist on around January 24th,
>> bro. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. I don't mean to keep pausing,
but does anybody have Do we even have my own coverage of like
those demon time? I
Is Riyle watching right now? I wonder if I could go to Riyle's
channel and find like my own coverage of Techone where I showed
these clips because I don't know if he'll still have them up.
I would love to get the timestamps, but you need to see like
the clips just to see how bad they look. They look really bad,
man. Um, hold on.
Ri's channel. We go to Techone.
I can't think. I'm trying to think of if um if Shimu grabbed
them in something or did I send them to Shimu at some point?
Let me see. Let me see. Let me see.
Teone. Techone. Techone.
Quit streaming.
Breaks a techone fan.
Techone. Techone.
Okay. I'll I'll look for it while we're >> Okay. Despite
this, John continued to make posts about me, X, and Twitch. He
even posted a live stream on Twitch or on around about February
6th where he called me a liar and threatened to sue me. I have
not heard directly from John since November 22nd, 2024, but his
frequent posts online insulting and threatening me have continued
to persist to the present day. So basically, she didn't go to
the police for about 8 months. She went to the police because
um
she was like, I'm going to go to the police, whatever that means.
She went to the police after 8 months. Um and then Teone was
uh and then she made a tweet. Technom started making threats
online which then uh she also at the same time around that time
was getting a lawyer so she got a lawyer to deal with this um
because she realized that this is not going to work. >> Oh
this would also be up right if he says like I'll post videos
of you if he were to say if he were to make the threat about
posting revenge which by the way that is the thing that I believe
he told her and we'll we'll have to go maybe to the civil case.
Uh, I believe that Teone essentially intimated to Pink Chu
that Frame had had wanted to post intimate videos, as in videos
of them like [__] or something online
when I think Frame had just posted like a a video of her like
driving up trying to say like, "I wanted to get back together
with Teone. He cheated on me." This is around Christmas, right?
We we've seen that video on stream where Tee and Pinky Chu pull
up at their place at what was Tekone and Frame's place on Christmas
Eve and Teone and Pikachu go inside. And I think Teone took that
recording. He tried to make it clear. He tried to make it seem
to Pinky Chu, this is what I remember, so I'm not 100% certain
on this. He tried to make it seem to Pinky Chu, if I recall correctly,
that what what Frame was actually doing was threatening to post
So, he would have known that that was like a concern for Pinky
Chu apparently. And then he was threatening to do it himself.
And then he was like threatening to post text conversations and
like uh oh, John made a post on X saying he would publicly post
text conversations, videos, etc. between him and I online.
>> Keep in mind, chat, this is all from the plaintiff.
This is not the defendant, which is Techone. This is from the
plaintiff, which is Pinkchu. So, this is her claims and what
happened. He even posted a live stream on Twitch on around about
February 6th where he called me a liar and threatened to sue
me. I have not heard directly from John since November 22nd,
2024. But his frequent posts online insulting and threatening
me have continued to the present day. This includes a comment
where he made on a Twitch stream on May 12th, 2025 where he said
he would go nuclear when the legal involvement between him and
I ends. Sounds similar.
>> He accused me of swatting him on around
>> on Twitch stream May 12th, 2025. I want to say that
might be it very possibly.
>> 2025 and said the world will know what you've done.
Late October, early November. That's when these instances have
caused me significant mental and emotional harm as he has a large
following and I receive hateful comments and messages frequently
from people who watch his content.
Every day I'm afraid John will act on his threats to post immediate
videos or photos of me. And I fear he won't ever stop posting
things online about me. >> immediate. He just misread.
He finally misread. Get [__] Misk. Not everybody's
perfect. Okay. Immediate. He said immediate. Post immediate videos.
That's intimate. >> Knows where I live and I'm concerned
that if he becomes angry enough, he will show up to my house
unannounced to threaten or harm me. For my safety, I want John
Roberts in order to stay away from me. Sexual abuse. Was the
respondent sexually abusive with you? Yes. Had the respondent
been drinking or using drugs? No. Damn.
Damn. So, this is just the first of hundreds of documents, chat,
just letting you know what's going on. Um, she's basically claiming
uh that
he was abusive. He would
she's claiming that he's abusive and that he would grab her and
force her to suck his dick and she had lip filler. And she has
proof that she got her lip filler removed and that was a time
that happened. and then six eight months later she went to the
police which I do feel the correct answer to assault allegations
or sexult in general is going to the police. Um I am someone
that's much more uh obviously someone that has been accused of
assault uh multiple times at this point. I am someone that is
very firm and I'm sure a lot of you are as well that you need
to go to the police that this is something that should not be
aired out to the public that this is something that you need
to go if it's a serious crime like assault you need to go to
the police. Um, and the problem is a lot of girls don't want
to go to the police because it's a he said, she said. Uh, they
need proof. They need evidence. Um, but so they don't want to
go. But I think that even just filing a police report really
can go pretty far. And these girls don't do that. Uh, which always
makes >> I'll be honest, I'm not listening to like Miss
Kev talk about um the >> believe that they're lying. Pinchu,
not only did she go to the the Travis County and issued a uh
police report, she also went with proof that she got her lip
filler removed and that techone
uh did this. But this is all just the first part. This is all
he said, she said. We'll see what happens. >> No, you're
supposed No, no, no. You're supposed to say um you're No, you're
supposed to say she went with proof and then the judge decided
that like there was obviously enough enough proof there to hold
him liable. That's That's your lie, Miss Skip. That's your lie.
Next thing.
She wants that money.
Okay. So, there's an insole viewer right there. Everyone wave
at him.
I I think so. Miz says she makes insane money. I feel like Miz
is like overselling it a little bit, but I don't think Pikachu
I think Pikachu sorry since she left. She definitely doesn't
need the money here anymore. She just wants this guy not to be
involved with her at all. Right. that he she just wants him to
off. I don't think she's not asking for money. There's no money
involved in this court proceeding. This is not a civil this is
not like a tort. There is nothing. You're not going for money
here at all. It is just a protect border hearing. >> Pink
Chu makes more money than me. Techone, Asmin combined. Just letting
you know. Um she is one of the biggest. >> No, she doesn't.
Gooners don't pay that much. Gooners pay a lot. But I'm sorry.
She's not making that much money.
Okay. More than Asmin Gold. Come on, bro. more than girls and
she does insane amounts of money. Her Instagram is massive. She
gets like millions of views every day. She's huge. Okay. She
does not need the money. She's massive. She's bigger than all
of us. She's huge, dude. She's huge. She's huge. She's huge.
Would you really say she's huge, Miss?
>> Would you really say she's massive?
Seems a little inappropriate to me.
>> Seems a little inappropriate. Okay. >> But it's
not the >> By the way, I think she makes like a ton of
money. I just I'm saying explicitly. I'm pretty confident that
like
>> I'm I'm personally pretty confident
that Asmigold would make more money for that was granted. >> So
literally, it already means that the document is validated by
a judge. >> See how Miss Kip talks through it. Um, I'm
not I He did get the protective order, so we'll go with that.
Um, and not only did he get a protective order, he got a pre
whatever it's called, protective order. So,
>> Who would do who would have >> anything to do
with the loser like
>> You know, that's a good question. Like, I just I don't
understand that. Like, forget all this stuff. He's ugly. Like,
I I just don't understand why Pink or any girl would go after
Tech. Like, he's not a good-looking dude. I don't get it. He
looks like he's the guy outside of a 7-Eleven near his high school
talking about how good his high school was and you know hoping
that one of his old buddies shows up and [__] and
like is sells alcohol to kids. I don't understand how
anyone likes TeeOne and then he opens his mouth and it's the
worst part.
Um,
was Pink rich before Tech or was that the case? I don't think
Pic was riched before Tee. I think she started to blow up at
the end of their relationship. And I think Pig Cho Pig Pingchu
blew up really this past year, but she was already making good
money from what I understand while they were dating. Um, but
not insane amounts of money, you know, not like
she she's not going for money. She I don't even think she wanted
money in this. She just wanted her lawyer fees paid. It's which
is not like an insane thing to ask. She didn't ask for like millions
of dollars or anything like that. Um, how do I That's in the
documents probably. We'll we'll go over
Um
to the honorable judge of said court application the Travis County
Attorney's Office by and through her attorney Hillary Riley is
making this application for a protective order on behalf of blank
blank. >> Now I think from what I remember this was the
same thing. >> Um is this the same document that I just
had? Let's see.
>> I'm pretty sure >> it might be. >> So this
might have been like modified to add some other stuff. >> The
prayer. Yeah, it seems like it's the same document. >> Like
it's possible there's some difference in the text here or difference
in the request. Maybe it was like changed slightly. >> Yeah,
[snorts] >> but I I thought it was the same one. >> Is
when is this filed? August 21st down here. So, this is >> what's
going on here. He's going through this
court to issue an export day protective order blah blah blah
blah. >> Uh location
and effective until the 3rd day of September 2025 at 11:59 p.m.
>> Okay. So, you remember when I did the post lining like
outlining the timeline here for Tech Toad? You guys remember
that uh that is the September 3rd is the day of the next hearing.
That is the day he retires. He after this this hearing right
here, which or sorry, after this right here, which this might
be an extension, I I didn't see it at the top or it might just
be granting it. But after the hearing on the third, where they
give an extension, that's where he's like, I'm going bye-bye.
>> The requirement of a bond is hereby waved pursuant to
section 83.003
title, I believe that is six, Texas family code. It is furthered
ordered that the clerk shall issue notice ordering respondent
to appear and respondent is ordered to appear before court in
the Travis County Criminal Justice Center. Uh which is where
this was uh and this is where on the 3rd day of September. So
chat this court case got pushed back by the way to now. So it
was supposed to happen in September but it got pushed all the
way back to January. And this is when I'm telling you when I
say that um court cases can get pushed back and delayed like
crazy. That's just how it is. It's insane how long the court
system takes
>> itakes forever.
>> Just the court date alone got pushed
>> um
the hell. Move this. Just the court date alone got pushed back
six months. Like that's crazy. 6 months it got pushed or was
that 1 2 3 4 like four and a half months. That's crazy.
>> yeah, it got pushed a couple times. >> Not just
once. It's further ordered that the clerk shall issue notice
ordering respondent to appear and respondent is ordered to appear
before the court in the Travis County Criminal Justice Center.
This is where they have to appear. Um,
>> So,
boop boop boop boop boop boop boop boop right here.
trying to record this. >> We all remember, okay, September
3rd, 2025. This is goodbye for now. I think that's like such
a crazy thing to me that like we get goodbye for now. The second
that that temporary protective order is extended that he's basically
like, "All right, I'm I'm done. I'm done streaming. I'm done.
I'm done, guys. I can't I can't not talk about it. I'm
It's just wild, right, how the dates line up like that just perfectly.
So, I'm glad that I'm getting a little validation through these
court documents. I feel like it's a although I guess I I knew
the timing, but it's just interesting to see it all laid out
on with other people. >> This is why TechOne didn't stream
for the past eight months. It's not because >> Oh, also
9:00 a.m. That explains why I in my head I was like, wait a little
bit there. It's like did he do it before or after? No, 9:00 a.m.
That looks like around noon, around like you know, midafter afternoon.
>> Mental health was anything. It's probably well it probably
was partially that but it is because Teone had this protective
order and he is so bad and cannot talk about not shut the up
about Pinku that he just needs to talk about her and just let
his bull out cuz the dude has schizophrenia and is insane >> that
his lawyer probably told him stop streaming. That is exactly
what >> God this guy mustor
consume some this guy must consume like just like media from
people who are incredibly informed who have like the best opinions.
The protective order granted here and should not be made into
a final protective order. The additional relief requested by
the applicant should not be granted and the court should not
make such other and further orders representing the parties as
deemed necessary and equitable. So he got a a part protective
order here that was issued.
>> This is temporary exparte is he still hasn't had a chance.
Exparte means without the other party, right?
So it's a it's a temporary protective order, I guess. TPO.
So expert just means that he's not there. That usually means
it's, you know, shorter or less severe because they're trying
to protect somebody without without, you know, even letting them
litigate their side. >> At least until the um the court
case was going to happen.
A person who violates this order may be punished for contempt
or court by a fine of as much as $500 or by confinement in jail
for as long as 6 months or both. I think that Tek would probably
rather enjoy jail than not talking about pink. No person, including
a person who is protected by this order, may give permission
to anyone to ignore or violate any provision of this order during
the time in which this order is valid. Every provision of this
order is in full force and effective unless a court changes the
order. It is unlawful for any person other than a a peace officer
as denied by section 107 penal code actively engaged in unemployment
as sworn full-time paid employee of a state agency or political
subdivision who is subject to a protective order to possess a
firearm or ammunition.
written uh admon admission on in ineligibility to possess firearm
>> Oh, let's go.
Ammonition.
That's a tough >> Sorry. Uh Miz has actually read wonderfully
here. He's actually read wonderfully. This is way better than
me reading. Okay. He's read wonderfully. But the couple that
he does get wrong, I do have to I do have to say
he's not allowed to do that. >> Look up bxism. I don't
think you just have TMJ. It's often from being under immense
emotional stress. Matty Moo. >> Yeah, I I we all know that.
What? Of course, everyone knows that I I'm emotionally deranged
and like over the years. Are you kidding me? And I'm also stressed.
One in chat if you're the
Uh firearm means any device designed, made or adapted to expel
a projectile through a barrel by using energy generated. Okay,
so obviously techone doesn't count by an explosion or burning
substance or of any device readily convertible to that use. Firearm
does not include a firearm that may have as an in inter integral
part a folding knife, blade, or other character. >> Y'all
keep talking about his jaw movements. I honestly haven't made
illegal by penal code chapter 46 and that is one an antique or
curio firearm manu manufactured before 1899.
So te can literally only own guns made in the like world war.
So like Tone was allowed to own a like a a barrel. That's basically
it.
Um, other than that, TeeOne in the law of world of Texas, which
is crazy to think, was not allowed to own a gun. So, basically
what this means, chat, is that the lawyer, the judge found that
the evidence to prove that Tek was uh at least stalking, abusing,
or whatever the orsaulting
Pinku, >> oh, was enough,
>> bro. Do you think his like titles of his streams would
be enough?
Jesus Christ. I'm like looking for this other stream in the background
while we listen to Miz here a little bit. Um because I I should
know most of the information in these documents. So I am sort
of letting Miz, you know, help. He's he's helping me out while
I produce the next part of the stream. But I'm looking through
this. I'm going to peel the skin off your body and then take
that skin and wear it over my face.
I shall claim the throne. He's leaving. Pain and suffering is
only the beginning. It's almost time. Exclusive YouTube them
all. Uh not again. Blah blah blah. Big reveals. The day of reckoning
is much sooner than ye think. I am not your only enemy. Oh, one
day I will ruin your life. You know who you are. You don't have
much time left. You will lose. BRO, WHAT? BRO, WHAT? WHAT? What
is this? Hold on. When is this?
What was this one? This is July 31st, 2025.
So, she would have filed the the
Jesus.
It's like two weeks before she files this. I'm like, I'm guessing
I'm guessing at some point she might actually think these things
are referring to him, right?
No, I understand that like I understand that
they might not literally be referring to her, but if I were her,
like that would feel confusing. No. Or concerning. It feels like
it would be concerning. I It does.
Do we have nails on YouTube? >> I just want to see if um
I just want to see if he talks how he talks about the beginning
of this. >> I'm so [laughter] [__] tired. It's
actually insane. Guys, this is not a one gamer subs day. This
is a two gamer subs day. Uh the the little goblin, man. The little
goblin short stream. I mean, let's be real. If a streamer is
streaming two hours, that's the same length as a featurelength
film. It is. I don't want to hear anybody say that that's short.
That is the length of the Superman movie. Okay. Uh listen, the
Little Goblin. >> The Little Goblin
Nightmare yesterday, dude. He diarrhea. He diarrhea. He diarrhea.
I appreciate you
>> Um and I immediately went to the gym. I
uh to I'm going wider now to use more of my pectoral. And then
I went to dips. Last time I did dip.
>> Okay. I don't think so. I don't think we see that. So,
I'm looking for I'm looking for
It might be this one.
>> I'm looking for one. Oh, no. No. No. Hold on. Not that
one. We're looking for
five months agoish.
Okay. We're looking for right after the August stream,
but I think he deleted the one I'm talking about. So, wait, what?
These keep moving in a weird way.
Oh no, we're up here. Okay, okay, okay.
Almost time.
He did like a super cheap.
>> August 9th, not here yet. >> I'm tired of being
copyright struck on YouTube. So, I'm literally doing a cold silent
opening. No more music.
>> It's around here, dude. I think I think he very possibly
got rid of
he very possibly got rid of the stream I'm thinking of
because I swear to God the stream I was thinking of
he does like it's just gota stream >> he just does like
a gotcha stream and
fine I'll find it at some point I'll message somebody I'll figure
it out okay >> we will find it we will find it >> sufficient
evidence that she was granted a protective order up until the
court case. Um, and he could not have a gun. He could not uh
talk about her. So, he went offline and basically didn't stream
for like 9 months. Um, it seems like because the court got pushed
back 6 months. He didn't stream for nine
So, Judge Todd D. Wong and Judge President, which I guess was
to judge granted this on August 21st,
20.
>> Judge Todd D. Long and Judge President. Thank God for
Judge President, guys.
That guy, that guy's a real one. That guy's a a real ass and
Okay. Judge President.
We love Jud Judge President. I'm sorry. I should be snarking
on Teto, not Misk. >> Judge President, which I guess was
two judge granted this on August 21st, 2020. >> Two judges.
Two judges. We got judge president and judge.
>> They granted it uh pretty quickly. Very >> We
love Miskf here. Okay. >> All right.
So, this is August 27th.
Note of application for protective order.
This is to John Robertson. This is Techone.
As application for protective order has been filed in the court
stated in this notice alleging that you have committed family
violence. You may employ an attorney to defend yourself against
this allegation. You or your attorney may but >> Ruben
donated $3. Rose got Lexia
>> required to file a written >> Ms. Lexia. Ms. Llexia.
Yeah. >> Answer by the application. >> Thank you,
Ruben. Ruben. >> Any answer must be filed before the hearing
of this application. If you receive this notice within 48 hours
before the time set for the hearing, you may request the court
to reschedule the hearing not later than 14 days after the date
set for the hearing. If you do not attend this hearing, a default
judgment may be taken and a protective order may be used issued
against you. The application for the protective order was filed
on August 21st, 2025. You are commanded to appear before county
court of law number number four at the Travis County Criminal
Justice Center which is here to show cause if you have why this
application for protective order should not be granted given
under my hands in seal of said court by Dana Lame Lemon. I'm
going to say lemon because it's more fun. Marcato, county clerk
on this 21st day of August and they wrote it all here that John
Robertson cannot own a gun and John Robertson is it is uh proven
that he has a protective order in the Travis
>> It's done.
It's done. So, he's got the he has a protective order. This is
not the protective order. This is the uh pre-protective order.
This is before he even got the protective order.
So, the judge found sufficient evidence to give that protective
order. They just don't give protective orders easily, chat. It's
very hard to get uh it's hard to get a restraining order, let
alone a protective order. And she got one with the evidence that
she already had. Uh Teone was already uh told that he cannot
uh own firearms and that TeeOne cannot uh contact her or anyone
around her ever for at least seven months. >> Dude, what
why would you make this? Why would you Why would you make this?
I do like it. I do. Thank you for making it. Okay. Thank you
for making it. All right. Thank you. Wait, what did he what did
he tweet when he first put this out? Was it something about wolves
inside of him or something? Was that the I have a wolf inside
of me or something? I need the I need the actual tweet if anybody
remembers it. Okay. >> Did Tek have a lot of guns? Does
anyone know that?
I wonder how many guns that guy had. He probably just bought
a
um trying to
my audience without a gun. That's not a true patriot. >> All
right. to John Robertson,
Austin, Texas. Greeting.
Whereas in cause blank pending on the docket of the county, Travis
County wherein is an applicant in John
Robinson or county criminal.
>> This is why I will say
it's cool to watch Msk over this stuff, but this is why I didn't
bother going to redact all these documents. I truly believe like
outside of the initial
application all of this stuff is fairly >> repeat the question
>> not interesting. I is not interesting at >> Getting
served
>> or it this is going into protective order is set for
September 3rd, 2025
when this is filed August 27th. 27th protective order is set
for September 3rd, 2025
when this is filed August >> I think these are possibly
two separate notices, right? He might the the actual temporary
notice or whatever that might have been if they granted that
because I'm guessing a hearing for protective order would be
actually legally disjoint quite possibly from a hearing for a
temporary exparte protective order. So you might do both of those
things. They might find that there's no reason to do the emergency
one. Let's say the guy's out of the country. They might say,
"Well, actually, we don't need to do an emergency thing. This
guy doesn't even live in the country. Like he he comes back here.
He's gone for 6 months. Why don't we just do the,
you know, this thing or something? I I'm trying to come up with
a scenario. It could exist where they don't think they have the
evidence to say we're not going to do the temporary one. Although,
I don't know. I just know this is what happened in the um this
is what happens with temporary restraining orders in other cases.
The Pixie case specifically. They said, "Hey, there's no reason
to believe that there's like a absolute there's not like a burning
need. Nobody's going to die or or be significantly harmed if
we don't grant this immediately. We can have a hearing on whether
or not to grant it." So, I would assume the same thing applies
to temporary protective orders where hey, if there's no if there
were no reason to do that, they wouldn't do it and they would
still have the hearing for the overall protective order, but
they did both. So, I'm guessing he's there's be some duplication
or seemingly >> Labor Day stuff. >> I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
>> Okay. This is signed by the clerk. All right. So, honorable
judge dimple dimple mahorta
county court at law number four Travis County
re John Robertson date of birth blank case number to the honorable
judge dimple please advise that I represent John Robertson date
of birth blank in regard to case number C1
chat if you uh grab that that's a $25 gift card to Applebee's
protective order hearing the case is currently pending in the
county court of law number four of Travis County Please direct
any correspondence regarding this matter to me via email
or via mail at 602 west12. Thank you for your uh courtesies and
please do not hesitate to contact me or my office with further
questions about this matter and that's tech lawyer.
All right. This automated service certificate of service was
created by the uh e filing system. The filler so you're getting
>> for continuance. Motion for
>> Okay. So >> motion to delay. Okay. So this is
the applicant verse John Robertson.
>> They do a continuence from here and they extend. I forget
why the initial one was extended without the full hearing. Honorable
judge of said court comes now the respondent and moves from this
court to continue the above entitled and numbered cause and would
show that this cause is currently set for a protective order
hearing on September 3rd 2025. The respondent of this court would
show that the court that attorney Goffrey Porier has requested
additional records to be provided to our office and request additional
time to receive these records. Mr. Porier conferred with assistant
court uh county attorney Hillary Riley on August 26th. Mrs. Riley
is in agreement with our request for continuence. The motion
is for continuence is not made to cause delay. Wherefore premises
considered, the respondent prays that the above numbered and
entitled cause could be continued on this 28th day of August
2025. So this is basically them saying that they want uh
they want to push this back and that uh Pink Choose lawyer agrees.
Oh wait,
ain't no way. Hold on. That was really That is, isn't it? per
year is the the guy requested additional records to be provided
to our office and request additional time to receive those records.
You're conferred with these people continuence is not made to
cause delay.
Okay.
So interesting that >> Riley is in agreement with our request
for continuance. The motion is for continuence is not made to
cause saying and that uh Pink Choose lawyer agrees.
>> Right. Right. >> Seems that way. All of Hongkey
star rail is apparently here saying end microone and end techone's
career please. >> Dude, the the VTubers do not love tech.
That's what I need. I need youers. You
>> The gotcha community are not crazy. I don't want those
people in my community. Please get out of here. >> Uh Miz
Jesus said for to forgive your enemies. Come on, bro.
Exactly. Come on, bro. Like you really want Like what? Jesus
said forgive my enemy en enemies. Come on, man.
Jesus would not made it as a kick streamer. I'll tell you that
right now. He would not have made it.
Jesus would have been cancelled with the Mcrafters in 2020. >> Exposed
Russell next release his 2025 Door Dash rap.
>> All right. Ordinance with the law in cause which commanded
to
>> I understand
>> I'm I'm going to we're speeding through some of these
cuz they're like whatever.
>> En numbered cause >> application for a subpoena.
So
>> for the following names witnesses whose testimony is
material to the respondent in this cause
so this is te's lawyer I believe trying to submit a subpoena
which I mean I expect for him to do and this is commanded to
summon at the court uh for the court hearing
I understand undersigned witness named in the subpoena acknowledge
receipt of >> so I find this I find this very curious and
I here's what I assume
and this is like my read and I don't know for sure. Okay,
I assume that this is like going to be somebody
who is called
for some reason to like discredit Pinky in general. I I feel
like this is somehow and I don't know for sure. I wonder if she
had, you know,
I I I don't know, man. But I just I assume that's my assumption
is like this person's like basically entirely unrelated. They're
just somebody who can like tell a story at discredit her >> uh
for the court >> or possibly say something embarrassing
that could be used to intimidate like drop stuff so it doesn't
get litigated. >> I understand
of a copy thereof and hereby accept service of the attached subpoena
will appear in court on >> his new girl. No, I doubt that
>> date and time is directed by the subpoena. Failure to
do any so there was no signature of witness for some reason.
Uh, Camila Mononttoya on behalf of Joffrey Porier.
What? Who the [__] is Camila Mononttoya?
>> That's like a parillegal at his office who received
the service. I'm pretty
That would be my first guess. >> On the uh Okay, so this
is the state of Tekin protection of blank applicant for Sean
Robertson.
Um, this was filed on November 5th, 2025 at 9:00 in the morning.
um in MLA format agreed order for the extension of a temporary
exparte protective order on this tor the day court heard the
respondents motion for >> well I'm saying that like I'm
guessing sorry it's I say that is the goal what what he would
say the goal is is there's important like evidence this person
has important testimony they have to that would speak to why
this person is pursuing this protective order against me or something
right that's what he would say but I'm guessing that what is
going to be there is like a story that's probably not super material
to any of the actual things,
right? That yeah, like it's not it's not overt intimidation.
It's like you you have the right to do that under the law, but
it [clears throat] sorry swallowed wrong. Uh but
do you get what I'm saying where it's like well this person this
officer might have some embarrassing things to say about you
like perhaps they made a house call when like something embarrassing
was happening. Maybe you like for example off the top of my head
let's say she had a domestic violence incident or something with
a partner from before, right?
And that Tek happens to know or happens to have found like the
officer who went and took that call,
right? And so while it has nothing to do with this case, perhaps
he's going to argue that, oh, something happened there, blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah, it should be introduced in this
case. That is what I assume is happening there because I've just
come to expect that from certain >> For extension of temporary
mother, the requirement of a bond are hereby waved pursuant to
section 83003
title 6 Texas family code. It is hereby ordered that the order
granted on August 21st titled a temporary exparte protective
order is extended until the third day of December 2025. Okay,
so they just basically got everything extended again. And then
this is the delivered via electronic filing
records request for cause blank application for John Robertson.
The dear Travis County civil clerk's office council for respondent
John Robertson respectfully requests a certified copy of the
exparte order for records signed granted and filed into the case
on 115.
So it's really not a big deal.
They're looking for court orders.
Uh this is state of Texas versus John Robertson. Disclosure to
the public or state is prohibited. Exparte order on respondents
motion for court order produ production uh production of documents
and or things is granted. Therefore, it is an order of court
that Austin Oaks Hospital is commanded to produce all items,
documents or things in the possession regarding treatment records
for blank. >> This is why I'll be real.
This is kind of why I I was shocked that she gave Miz permission
to cover this stuff because this is the kind of that I think
is
probably inappropriate.
Um I don't really think that this stuff should be covered to
be honest with you.
Um but now it's being covered publicly so I feel like I can comment
on it. I just wouldn't have been I wouldn't have been the person
who wanted to like break this personally.
So, basically what they're trying to do, I believe this might
be trying to find out about the lip filler if I'm going to
Um, and that they're
>> So, does that correspond with early in the stream? Hold
on. What are the dates on the the lip filler stuff? Give me a
second. I'm going to take a look.
Uh, hold on. I'm going to try to figure this out really quickly
for myself. Is this what I need?
No, that's not it. What about this one?
Is this the one I wanted? No, hold on.
This one?
Wait, why are these downloading? No, don't download.
Sorry. I'm trying to see out of these documents like which one.
Um, Nope. Nope. Not finding them. God damn it. Okay. I don't
know which one I'm looking for now.
Nope. They're going to try to get
>> We could go back in the stream a little bit. That's
what I could do. Hold on. kind of maneuver around. Where are
we at here? We're at an hour 4249.
Okay.
Pull up the Miskuit VOD here. If we go back in the VOD, I'll
just go to where he read through some of this stuff. It was right
here. The lip filler thing is
May.
So, I don't know. I don't know if this is the lip filler. Austin
Oaks Hospital
uh procedures of that to show that she did get her lip filler
fixed uh and that the boob job was >> Danny, how's it going?
those records are to wit any and all documents, computer data
or other documentation that are currently in her possession or
the possessions of your employee or agent. Said production shall
be made in full and returned sent to defiant within 30 days.
Okay, so they're trying to get the court stuff from the Austin
Oaks Hospital.
Uh, after reviewing the attached order, we find the wording.
District clerk should read, "County clerk, may we have it corrected.
Thank you for the attorney in this." Uh, thank you for your attention
this matter. All right. Defense. So, this is State of Texas John
Robertson. Defense notice of filing of business records accompanied
by affidavit.
comes now. John Robertson by and through his attorney and files
the defense notion of filing business records with accompanying
affidavit in support thereof would show the following. Under
rule 902 of the Texas rule of criminal evidence, the defense
hereby gives notice of the file the following business records.
Copies of blank records from the Austin Oaks Hospital with the
business records affidavit signed by blank custodian of records
employed by Austin Oaks Hospital. The attorney for the state
of Texas, Hillary L. Riley was pro uh provided a copy of the
originals of the above mentioned business records and the affidavit
on November 20th that has been filed. So Pinkchu has uh Pinkchu's
lawyer, which I believe is Hillary O'Reilly, has copies of the
records of her going to Austin Oaks Hospital for her procedure
and for the uh the issue that's going on. So she
receipts, man. That's what this tells me is that she has the
receipts.
And this is the last thing that I have right now is applicants
agreed motion for extensive of temporary exparte protective order.
The agreed motion for extension of temporary exparte.
>> It feels so gay to like say
I have like other commentary here that I'm just >> The
order is bought by applicant Linda Ashley Lamar. >> Talk
about it at a different time. >> Okay, we've got this O'Reilly.
It's all the same.
Okay,
so basically chat, the big thing is this.
Where was it?
It's this. Why can't I find it? It's her her stating
this. What? Austin Hoax deals with mental stuff. This guy's a
special guy. This guy's a pretty silly guy. That's why personally,
okay, personally,
yeah, I this is why you could just assume that the techone stuff
is in bad faith, right? That's why you can assume stuff like
this, cuz the techone stuff is obviously in bad faith. Um Oh.
Oh, apparently. Um Oh,
I might I might not feel um quite so bad for a legal mindset
now. Hell, man. I didn't watch the rest of that.
So, if you guys remember that Shmu tweet from earlier, >> it's
hard >> right here.
>> Apparently, legal mindset like before covering that
document where all this stuff was happening, right?
I do believe he talks through like that same thing. why they
wanted those records, why Tech people were talking through those
records. Wanted those records. This is just going to come out
like it's all kind of in the public now. So, I'm probably just
going to talk through it because I don't know what else to do
to be honest with you. So, I assume they wanted those records
cuz they're going to try to say this person's mentally unstable.
They're mentally ill. They they are not reliable. You can't trust
them. They're mentally ill. They're mentally ill. They're mentally
ill. And legal mindset is a part of that that group of people
who are going to help set that up, right? who want to help set
that up, who are invested in helping to set that up and and then
he does this thing where he cries about his mental health struggles.
I just think it's complete and utter like he's just a total piece
of garbage. It's crazy. But that'll be why they want those records.
Let's keep in mind Tekone diagnosed openly unmedicated schizophrenic
according to him. Okay. But apparently Pikachu is the person
we don't think should be credible apparently. But in any case,
okay, I just I was trying not to cover this stuff because I was
like, "Oh, I knew I could tell I could just tell from the way
they requested records when I read through this. I'm like, bro,
I could see exactly what's going on here. I could see that she
was having like some kind of mental health struggle and that
they're going to try to bring it up to smear her to say, "Well,
no, she couldn't possibly be reliable." I I could feel in my
bones when I was reading through this and then yeah, I did the
same look up Miskf did for the for the hospital and I was like,
uh, yeah, I see exactly where they're going with this and I I
didn't want to bring it up cuz I'm like, oh, this is a piece
of thing to do and I don't want to draw attention to it now.
It's just all going public. So, like, what would you even do,
right?
It's just it's so annoying to me how these people act. I'm gonna
have to go I have to start being on Twitter more so I can start
correcting people because this is so stupid to deal with. I don't
know. I get I get so annoyed, man.
like to go and talk about your mental health struggles and then
to you you know exactly what you're doing, right? I I haven't
gotten a chance to watch his stream yet either because he doxes
he doxes people so much that I can't go through his stream. The
same people he's crying for. Oh, I empathize with their issues.
Doxing them so much that I can't even cover his stream and point
out how he's being a scumbag.
It's just purifying flames, man. Got to cauterize the wound that
is a lot of this space. All right. Purifying flames. Not in a
violent way. Just like it's going to be painful for a lot of
people, but it has to be done. Okay. Egotistically painful. Just
has to be done, dog. It just has to be done. It's
some brutal stuff, man. These people really suck.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, anyway.
Or we watch a miskiff.
Watch him walk through this a little bit more.
Maybe he'll have the same outrage that I do about it. Um, yeah.
Uh, this this said like I I tried to like orally her. Well, did
you consider that she went to a mental hospital once? You consider
that she might have had like mental issues? Maybe you just shouldn't
listen to her. Maybe she's like crazy. Maybe you should Oh, she
does Only Fans. She's like a mentally ill. Oh sh. Oh well, if
you want to if you want to if you want to trust a mentally ill,
I guess you could do that. Shut the up.
God, the difference between Teone
and Pikachu is that Tecttone
doesn't get treatment. Is that Teeone monetizes own mental illness.
Okay. And for some reason, we accept that.
It's crazy. >> Who's John? John is Tee. I don't think this
is about Tee. Why would she want the documents for TechOne, right?
That doesn't make any sense. >> He uh I think he doesn't
quite understand, but it's it's whatever. >> It is the
order of the court that Austin Oaks Hospitals commanded to pursue
produce all item documents or things in their possession regarding
treatment for blank date of birth blank from July 28, 2024 to
August 2nd, 2024.
August 2nd, 2024 or 2024.
So, I'm guessing uh this seems to be around the time here's the
other part of the narrative they'll try to weave is looks like
around the time they broke up, right?
Was in July of 2024, I
Right. That's when they broke up. So, I'm guessing she was having
like they were pretty techone was pretty open about talking how
she was like depressed. I think she talked about how she was
depressed and having a hard time. I think, by the way, it's like
a really cool story that she was she was like super depressed,
super out of it in like July of 2024.
By January of 2026, she is one of the highest earning models
on like uh Only Fans or whatever. And I don't think she even
does nudes.
Like, it's a it's a cool story. >> July 28th, if we go
back to the protective order that she wants. >> Yeah, it's
not going to line up. It's going to line up with when they broke
up. He knows they broke up in July. He's just not putting the
timeline together. This is why. Okay. This is why, you know,
you need the experts sometimes, okay? You need the people who
are used to tracking these timelines. Misk is an incredibly entertaining
guy. I could only hope to have, you know, onetenth of his dancing
potential, onetenth of his entertainment potential. But in terms
of tracking events that happen over a timeline, hey, I'm second
to none. >> When did she say that he around what time did
she force him to do that? Let's >> Yeah, after I moved
out in July 2024.
Oh. Um, that would be a question is when did she first make her
I'm guessing Legal Mindset went through this stuff, right? That's
why it would be nice for me if I if I could go over his stream.
That would be nice. I'll have to go and maybe clip it with some
people or something. Maybe we do a stream after this or something.
Um, that might be interesting Patreon content. I don't know how
many Patreon subs we have anymore, but haven't been doing content
there. That could be interesting Patreon content to go through
his um his stream and clip that with people. It's a little late.
Hold on. How much time we got on the stream? 40 minutes.
Uh, I'll commit to doing a Patreon stream where we go over that
legal mindset stuff and clips of and figure out after this. I'll
do any Patreon supporter stream after this and we can go and
figure things out and just see. We can watch it and won't have
to worry about the the info in there. Okay. The PII.
All right.
We'll do that. We'll watch his uh whatever his stream was. We'll
go through that. Okay, I'll commit to a Patreon if we don't get
more time, which by the way, I'm going to up the amount. I need
I need more than just the 30 to do more hours here, so I wouldn't
mind doing that Patreon content to be honest.
After I moved out in July 2024, I made a post on X about my experiences
assault corion, but I did not identify a specific perpetrator.
Uh John made a post. When did she say that she gave him head
and he she didn't? March 2024. This was July 2024.
Dude, timelines are a real struggle for
>> What? What would she possibly >> around the time
they broke up? It's probably a really bad breakup. I'm >> she
wanted this stuff.
>> What would she possibly have?
>> No, this is um this is them.
>> I think this is TTO's people who are applying for mental
hospital.
What would you possibly have at a mental >> Yeah. So,
uh there's an order of the court that these people are commanded
to produce this to tech people,
right? The
commanded that you have to take tech tech people have to produce
their
for him. I mean, I guess technically it could be
no records for blank. I mean, it's sort of given away by the
fact that this is redacted, right? Yeah.
That's his look. Lawyers requesting >> I'm kind of sitting
here thinking it seems entirely possible to me that
uh how do I say it? I don't know if maybe there's a miscommunication.
I feel like she wouldn't have wanted this out there. I do feel
bad that this is out there. It feels when people have to pull
up like this, use against you, you know, about her. Read my me
like my last message. is
>> defense file that I think they're trying to give evidence
of schizophrenia to use his offense and blame it on all that.
>> Not unless you redacted
name. [snorts]
He did a talk a lot about schizophrenia is what people told me
that he told about
take was and I quote
it was called a villa down here for >> and you obviously
know I am not a doctor so I don't know what the [__]
that means but if you look it up and this is things he admitted
to is that he would tell her what to take.
>> Um yeah redacting the hospital name would have been
important. Yep. Yep. Could have been
>> a bill twisted rope. There's a whole voting
antiscychotic medication that treats schizophrenia, bipolar one
disorder, depression, autism related irritability, and and Tourette's
>> what are we? >> He made his girlfriend who doesn't
have any of those things go get that because he said to go do
it. >> How do you know she doesn't have any of those things?
I I don't know that she doesn't have any of those things.
I It's none of my business to tell you the truth. She might not.
She might not. And I, by the way, Teone shouldn't be even if
she did have any. >> She's autistic. She >> Tone
shouldn't be prescribing it. That's not right. >> And she
did. She did. Yeah. That's pretty crazy. Okay, so I think that's
everything. Let me make sure.
let's see. Wait,
there's apparently 24 files. I only have 15. What?
Hold on. There is 24 files.
So, where were we, boys? Agreed. Order for extension. Order of
representation. I want to see what TechOne has to say. Okay,
so they they go to Oak's Hospital. They want that stuff. I don't
know what that stuff really is. Court email. All right. Comes
now. John Robertson buy and through his attorney and files the
defense notice of filing business records with a company affidavit
in supports thereof with filing. It's got to be him to get rid
of John Robert. John Robertson is totally completely allowed.
I did not tell him to get rid of John Robertson's name because
techone has said his name a thousand times. So it's pink records
from Austin Oaks Hospital with the business records affidavit
signed by blank. So Pink went to a mental hospital. >> I
Yeah, I don't know why. I feel like
this doesn't matter and I It's very weird to me that he went
through it this much, but it's fine, you know. It's fine. It's
fine. It's fine. It's fine. >> It's a mental health clinic.
What does that mean? What is a mental health clinic? Isn't that
like
>> means um she
dude
I just don't have judgment for people on this. I I'm like it's
you can feel the um
you feel like the judgment and I I I don't want to I won't hold
that against him cuz some people are just you know some people
don't get it at all but it feels to me cuz that's exactly why
she doesn't want it out right is she knows that there will be
immediate so I I think I think info like this possibly stuff
about her lip filler as well I think she filed a motion to seal
she didn't want this stuff published right she wanted stuff around
her medical info um redacted,
right? Oh, I'm talking about Miskf. Obviously, that's why that's
why Teto wanted to do it. So, I think um like Pinky didn't want
this stuff out there, which it it sucks that it's out there,
but it's it's literally Misk is kind of showing why she doesn't
want it out there is that it's like people can go to these places
and they're they're going to be fine. It's just like it's somewhere
you go if you're having like um like a rough moment in life.
again. Um, my grandmother went to somewhere like this several
times.
Was totally normal. Took care of me like the entire time I was
a little kid. Okay. Totally had no problems. Had like some rough
moments. Ended up in places like this a couple times. It's I
just I wish people could be more understanding. It It really
is. It's
I also feel like it's also not my brand at all to talk about
stuff like this. So, I'm just >> You go to a mental state
like you you check yourself in, right?
This is after they broke up. It is. It's a It's a You like I
I went to one, right? I went to one and it sucked and you're
just around insane people
>> Traumatized and depressed. Yeah. I'm not sure it maybe
it's therapy. I really don't know, chat. But there's something
interesting. Why does Techton
want these documents? And >> oh, he's maybe he's figuring
it out. Maybe he figures out the direction to go with this. Okay.
Um Lady Boy Mindset. Well, Lady Boy Mindset was doing this while
Msk was live. I think he probably didn't mean to publish the
stuff if I'm if I'm being honest with you. I don't think he would
have meant to publish this stuff or he would have censored the
hospital name. He probably just didn't realize this is what was
going on here cuz he's figuring it out as he goes.
But yeah, why is why does Techo want to >> copies of her
records at a hospital? Yeah, maybe it's cuz he felt crazy to
pee again.
I don't know.
the following. Teone wants her uh records of Austin Hook's hospital,
which is a loony bin. So, she went to a looney bin, and Teone
wants those records because of I don't know why. I really don't.
Let's keep reading the book.
So, so far what we got is Pink Chu basically said, "Tectone
really insensitive after you just >> insulted her. Teone
is a stalker. Teone is a weirdo. And Teone is a freak. Techone
did all these horrible things and this is what she's accusing
him of. Um,
TeeOne uh she showed evidence of that and got a temporary protective
order and wants a full protective order. That is what she's going
to court for. She wants a protective order on TechOne. Um, and
the judge said there was enough.
>> How do we get these docs? Uh, it's difficult to say.
So, originally we thought Teone definitely leaked them. I still
lean towards like I believe Techone leaked this stuff. Probably
probably, but the somebody on Twitter did say like I'm the guy
who leaked this and he gave a method for finding it through the
Travis County website. I'm not really going to talk about it
any more than that. Like basically some guy came along and said,
"Well, here's how you can find it." I verified that you can find
them that way. You can find the same portal or whatever. So,
I'm not totally sure which way. Um, it's not it's not obvious
that you have to basically
it's very not obvious and I it
uh it's hard to believe if the guy didn't actually give the the
way to do it. It's hard to believe that he would have just found
it. But evidence probably to pro to prove that tee needed at least
a temporary order. Then they uh they pushed back the date of
the court date 6 months. And she's saying that Tek was abusive.
He was uh he insulted her and would force her to do things he
didn't want to do. Um so let's keep
This agreed motion for extension for a temporary expert protective
orders brought on by applicant blank. This is set is presently
set for the applicants. >> I think he's through this
>> really not anything interesting. >> There is I'm
trying to think. I think there's essentially nothing other than
they're trying to subpoena this >> application for a subpoena
>> other than this like police officer they're trying to
subpoena. I think there's nothing else interesting here except
maybe
the
protective order at the end. The sorry the seal request at the
end. >> Just a subpoena to the judge of the county court
of law number four of Travis County, Texas. You will please >> like
we're going to see this same sub
multiple times. >> Greetings. You are committed at law
number four of Travis County, Texas. She
continue applicant's motion for continuance. Okay. So the motion
is to still continue this the final protective order. Holy crap.
That's just so many times that they're just pushing back this
court case. To the judge of the county court law number four
of Travis County, Texas. You will please issue subpoena in accordance
with the law and above styled and number same thing.
Motion of extension. Applicant's motion for extension of temporary
exparte. Holy. There's just dude
applicant's motion for witness to appear electronically. Okay.
What happened? The motion for witness to appear electronically
is brought by applicant blank who shows in subtective blank applicant.
Uh that one was
I believe for so here's the motion to seal or whatever. Um
oh no up here electronically and then there's a motion to seal
records. The previous one is for plastic surgeon who I assume
is going to talk about the >> first John Roberts applicant's
motion to seal records. A motion for conf confidentiality order.
This motion is to seal records and motion for confidential order
is bound by blank applicant who shows in support. This is an
action originally arising of the Texas family code and the documents
filed in this case are not subjected to the standards of sealing
court records set forth in rule 76. The sealing of the records
is in shown action will not have an adverse effect for the public
health or safety and the records do not involve matters that
should be available to the general public.
Blank request that all records which contain her information
and that are subjected to the health insurance probability and
accountability HIPPA in this case to be sealed. Blank requests
a confidentiality order to prevent disclosed sensitive health
information to third parties. The disclose of which could be
caused by injury to blank. Blank praise that the court what is
praise? The court grants the motion to seal records in motion
for confidentiality order. Wait a minute.
So pink wanted the court case to be sealed. She wants um
blank applicant who shows in sport
is an action originally rising Texas family
subject to the standards for sealing court records. The documents
filed in this case are not subject to the standards for sealing
records court records set forth in rule six. So they're saying
there are you can make exceptions under this this Texas um family
code civil procedure rule saying the records in this action will
not have an adverse effect on the public health or safety. The
records do not blank requests all that all records which contain
her information
and that are subject to HIPPA. So basically she's saying anything
in here that like deals with her health,
she's requesting that those things be sealed. So she says, "Well,
everything here could be sealed, like the these records aren't
actually under the same rules as everything else that that you
know, basically Texas, I'm assuming, has some form of the sunshine
law."
based on that you could seal like stuff here then and that the
fact that the sealing of these records won't have an effect on
public health, public safety or whatever that it won't affect
how the court is evaluated then could you please seal anything
that has to do with my health
request a confidence confidentiality order. So she didn't want
anything confidential getting out about this. This is why I was
kind of like, this is why I wasn't covering this is she basically
didn't want any of this stuff out. But once once both Legal Mindset
and Misk are both covering it, it's like, well, it's it's out
and we might as well talk about it cuz otherwise it'll only be
people who have no concern and no consideration for this person
who will be talking about it, right? Yeah. So anyway, it's basically
saying she doesn't want any of the health records out. She doesn't
want any of her health records out. Nothing for the transcript,
nothing from anything in this case that includes her health records.
She doesn't want any of that put out. So it' be like redacting
anything that involves your health stuff.
Okay.
Yeah. And
anyway, so request confidentiality basically just saying don't
bring any of that stuff up to prevent tech from mentioning it
or other people from mentioning it. Uh it feels pretty up that
this website has bad security that could be breached and then
people with no like no authentication, no no credentials can
can view all of it. Um, I for example just went and checked like
a document specifically just to see something here and yeah,
it's like it's it's just all there. Like it's all open still
and
it feels really to me that she had all the stuff leaked. What
can you do, man? What can you do, man? What can you do, dog?
What can you do?
Them's the brakes, guys. Them's the
All right. I do actually want to take some time to watch it.
Okay.
Oh, you know what we could do?
Nah, we should try to finish as much of this as we can. Let's
we'll we'll do some of this and then we're going to go to the
Patreon. We'll do the legal mindset if you guys are interested.
I don't know if anybody's interested, but I I do I'm probably
just going to go watch it on my own. So, if you guys aren't interested,
then that's totally fine. Uh if I want to play if I'm going to
play Rivals, if Quimman's around, and I don't know if you will
be, if Quman or Lav are around in like two hours, I'd probably
do some rivals.
Send it for a game or two.
Nah. Nah. Nah. I'll I'll wait. If If people are around in a couple
hours, we could do Rivals.
No, you can't. Extreme Dad. You could pay $5. You have $5. You
have $5. You're still literally still You can pay $5. It's $5
for the Patreon tier.
Lowest one. Okay. I'm I'm probably just gonna watch it by myself
anyway, so like I might as well just turn it on. No, no, I don't
find it hype. I don't think it's funny. I I get it. I'm sorry.
I don't mean to yuck your yum, buddy. But Jesus, not a fan. >> That
said, TTO was effed in my opinion. >> I thought it was
going to get better and it didn't get better. >> Say anything
then blatantly lie and say he won and flip the script like does.
Asmin just wants to let Tech stand for himself. He probably doesn't
need backup. This probably things probably won't end well for
Misgif. And we just got this uh cursed picture as >> what?
How will it end bad for me? And look how this guy's just constantly
just going through all the other bad stuff. He's just basically
saying like, "Amin's a real man. As a real man, this is how it
should be done."
Okay, then why didn't he do that for me?
If this is what a real man does, why did he just specifically
not do this for me?
Why if this was the same thing that happened to Assan [__]
he would not >> see uh [__] hates you >> not
do it as well.
is a real man because he won't comment on his friends allegations.
That's what a real man does. They sweep it up for their buddies.
>> Maybe Miz may be suing everyone and flailing trying
to go down with him. But with all of his insane threats, supposed
evidence, throwing everything and everyone under the bus, constant
lies, he has already decimated.
>> Dude,
do these guys like this guy's just picking the most ridiculous
claims. I've seen Twitter. 95% of people are on my side and they're
saying even I hate miskf but techone's a piece of >> but
he said he knew more about it than public and techone was going
to win and he said it with his
>> like most of Twitter is hating techone from what I've
seen I don't see these comments this guy is scrouching the internet
desperately trying to cling on to Asmin looking for these comments
>> a real man this is how it should be done miz baby suing
everyone and flailing trying to drag everyone down with him,
but all his insane threats, supposed evidence, throwing everything
under the bus. He's already decimated and ruined his own cases
by doing exactly what he's trying to sue for. I will say being
this active while actively being in like a defamation case is
not a good idea at >> You're right. It's not a good idea
if it's something that I'm saying that's wrong. It's not a good
idea if I have something to hide. I have nothing to hide. That's
why I say I have nothing to
>> Nothing to hide. is is I'm suing Emmy for stalking and
I'm suing Emmy for saying that I uh for for defamation and assault.
I'm suing her for defamation because I didn't assult her and
I didn't stalk her.
>> Point blank.
>> Um and for Asmin,
I he defamed the out of me and he talked about my case and and
my non-stop,
but he won't talk about Lucari and he won't talk about Team.
No, she didn't stalk me. She claimed I stalked her. And I'm suing
her for defamation on that.
And it's just it's just an echo chamber. It's like, oh, it's
it's real bad to talk, dude. I you don't need to talk about me
to talk about Lukari. You don't need to talk about me to talk
about TechToM. You I do I'm not required. I'm not in that instance.
You don't need to talk about >> Oh, especially getting
into all these dramas and, you know, going on these skits rants.
It's like I don't know if he's still >> you're really trying
to make me look bad here when Techone has the most crazy allegations
that in the transcripts he shows and says he admitted to doing
he admitted to doing
>> taking all those uh drugs or whatever but hopefully
he's mentally
there. So >> taking all the like, so you're trying to say
I am not a credible source at all because I'm taking a bunch
of drugs and everything I said is lies
and everything that everyone else has evidence on that also commented
that they have evidence and said that it's true what I said.
But this guy just did no research and he doesn't want to do research
because he has enough. He said Asmin was a good boy and he's
doing the right thing and Msk is a schizophrenic psychopath and
he's a bad guy and Misk is the reason why all he's failure and
let's move on from this shall we? >> He gets into his own
stuff quite a bit guys but it's okay because
he's he's a he's helping. Okay, he's
>> Also,
dude, this more Pegasus guy is such a I can't believe how many
bad content creators are online. And I don't mean bad as in like
bad people. I it's not even a moral judgment on this guy. I have
no idea what he's like in real life. But Jesus Christ, man. The
Hassan's bad stuff's got to go. Okay. >> We had this tweet.
Grapes stopped streaming with his whole chest. Asmin Gold said
he knew more than the public about this case and that everything
would be fine. Now he's trying to act like he didn't know a thing.
But >> how do you possibly protect Asmin here? >> By
the way, that's not what he said at all. He said that yes, he
does know more about the case than the public, but he never said
that, oh, everything is going to be perfectly fine or anything
like that. Hassan responds at >> commenting on the Teetone
drama. Um, I mean, I've now had three of my friends uh actually
more than that uh had their lives ruined by accusations that
were not proven in a in a court of law.
And I'm tired of it. I'm tired of having people accuse people
that I know of something of a crime and they expect me >> Man,
I think as a gold could have stood by Rich and Rich would have
been fine. I think Rich could have kept streaming.
Rich was in like a pure he said she said with somebody with like
no particular evidence. He didn't even have to like step away
really. Asold just dipped on the guy. Okay.
They they just all dipped on the guy. I don't like that he says,
"Oh, well, they've been cancelled." No, you cancel Rich. You
cancel Rich.
>> They expect me to commit to removing this person out
of their life,
but they won't even commit to seeking justice.
They want me to be justice. I'm not
>> I've had this happen a lot like throughout my streaming
career. We all know who it is. We all Everybody knows who it
is. And at the end of the day, I am I am so tired of having to
pretend like this is some kind of evil thing when a crime was
not proven to be committed. I am not the police. I am not an
investigative authority. I do not have jurisdiction over this.
To expect me to excommunicate or to remove a person from my life
based off of accusations that are unproven and you did not even
try to go to the police. Get the
Rich deserves it for forgiving Asmin. Retroactively deserved.
Damn.
>> As of yet, Pink hasn't said anything on the Twitter
X base, but if she releases anything, I'll be sure to let you
guys know in another video. But Asmin Gold spoke out on the situation
between Teone and Pink in the following clip. >> Commenting
on the Techone drama. Um,
I'm not sure when I'll be back, but my mind is clouded. I'm just
angry every day. I'm crashing out over nothing and I don't want
my resentment guiding me. I I see where I'm headed and I don't
like it at all. I'm not saying I'm saying things I don't mean.
I'm tilting out over the smallest things. The worst thing is
I can't even explain to you guys why I'm so angry and that's
what's Oh, uh Shimu did make a follow-up tweet on the privacy
situation. Okay. With regards to Pink Shoe, regarding the Teetone
court case leaking, I've received details which make it a possibility
that it was not Tecton, but a coding error in which the in the
Travis County court portal which illegally populates the case,
which I would say illegally, which
I mean, it might be illegally given that stuff's not supposed
to be publicized, like some of the stuff in there, but incorrectly.
It it doesn't mark privacy correctly. Um, this case is supposed
to be sealed and it isn't and isn't accept accessible except
via glitch. The user still joined Tech's Discord and only posted
the case itself 15 minutes after joining, which is incredibly
suspect, but it was possibly a third party.
Eh, I dude, I don't know, man. Like, okay, maybe it's like this
third party.
Uh, it it seems really sus. I don't know. Regardless, Tees Discord
hosted his victim's docs and private medical records for hours
and was the origination of this of its circulation.
origination
origin of its circulation.
Sure, sure. Sure. Okay. So, there's the the follow-up Shimu post
here. Good stuff. Good stuff. All right. We're going to streaming
me the most
over everything. I'm going to break. Hopefully, not for long,
but no streams for a while. This date that I have to keep waiting
for is getting closer, but the wait is harder. I plan on making
some YouTube videos and just talking and tweeting every now and
then, but nothing too much. I need to get my head straight again.
Uh, appreciate y'all. Uh, bye for now. So, as somebody who knows
more about this than the public, I think that
>> Yeah, maybe they maybe they could subpoena the records.
Yeah, I think that could make sense. >> Back all of this
is going to make a lot more sense. I'll certainly say that. So,
don't worry about it, guys. Tech >> um this guy would have
already been part of the Discord already if he was a fan. No,
unless burner for a fan. Yeah, it just seems really weird. And
then the guy made a post from his Twitter account, I think. We're
not really uh Can I describe it?
His Twitter account just has really weird history. Like super
weird history for what it's like in post will be back. It's not
going to be a big deal. >> I don't know how to describe
it. It's a very bizarre situation. It's just odd. Like I don't
know how else to describe it, man. It's just odd.
>> He said that yes, he does know more about the case than
the public, but he never said that, oh, everything is going to
be perfectly fine or anything like >> I'll certainly say
that. So, don't worry about it, guys. Techone will be back. It's
not going to be a big deal. Everything's totally fine. >> Your
move.
Your move. Your move. >> And so, uh, yeah, that's it. >> And,
uh, hiding from the bot bands. Well, why would he hide from the
bot bands when his last stream had 11,000 viewers? That doesn't
even make any sense. What are we talking about here? And so,
uh, is he pregnant? He could be pregnant. That could be it. Yes,
that's it. He has to give He's going to have to give birth and
that will be it. And, uh, yeah. So, we told you. So he told you
lies offstream too. Why would he tell me what do you mean lies?
Like I mean no I I like has it ever occurred to you that maybe
I know more about a lot of these situations than the public would
be aware of? Like I mean I I you know I've known Techone now
for like what three or four years.
This tweet when Grape first stopped streaming with his whole
chest. Asmin Gold said he knew more than the public about this
case and that everything would be fine. Now he's trying to act
like he didn't know a thing. By the way, that's not what he said
at all. He said that yes, he does know more about the case than
the public, but he never said that. Oh, everything is going to
be perfectly fine or anything like that. >> I don't know
what Miz is pausing on. What are we pausing for here?
>> We were here. >> Oh, yeah. Oh, high five. Cool.
>> Yeah. No, the the more Pegasus guy. >> That's
actually
I just hope that literally anybody around. Okay. Basically, just
anyone. I hope anyone.
I want to watch all of the more Pegasus coverage. This guy is
such a >> for like um less than or like an hour. >> I
didn't know you came in.
>> Yeah, I came in. But then I thought you heard me, but
I didn't know you're here. What's up? >> I don't even know
what >> you I don't think a lot of you. He will face you
for
Ka anyway. Defamatory on >> Wait, how do we how do we get
a defamation lawsuit? said, "Hassan obviously jumping on it like
he jumps on Asmin's pee pee." Hassan has said some of the most
defamatory [__] on stream. Does anyone honestly think
he isn't going to whine and [__] about when he gets
served for defaming someone? Plus, Asan shocks his dog. [laughter]
Never forget Ka. Anyways, moving on to Ms. continuing demon time.
He's trying to expose Tactone some more. Ms. Kiff shares his
notes from Tekton's court appearance and times that she didn't
want to be recorded. Easy. kick.com/misk
>> The judge said delete every
Misk might have a point with that one. That's that's possible
that like Misk might have a point with that one. Like putting
the watermark all over the place so it's in all of your clips.
That actually might be smart. Um, just keeping the watermark
there for like the pure the URL where all the content is, >> everything
about your phone or I'm you
top left
>> order to remove and delete and get rid of all pictures
and videos without her permission and even with or he will face
criminal charges. He is forced to pay her attorney fees around
$50,000. The protective order is for 10 years. Chat, you I don't
think a lot of you understand how crazy it is to get a protective
order. Bro, could they not do 1080p in India? Like, what the
[__] is this? That means that when Tekon goes on
planes, he has to do something that it's going to follow Tecton
for the next 10 years of his life. It is serious.
It is serious. And he can't own guns. He can't own any type of
weapon in his house. They're all going to get seized. He can't
have any of it. He can't talk about her or any time can uh can
talk about her on stream. He can't own guns and ammunition. He
must stay at least 200 yards away from her. And if they happen
to be in the same place at the same time by accident, he must
leave immediately. Right?
So I think this is still the results of the civil case and this
is basically the consequences or implications of it. Again, it
doesn't mean like the essay is confirmed or something, but it
does mean what it actually says there that he has to stay away
from her. >> The way he's saying right, he's trying to
make his audience be like, "Yeah, okay, Miskf, you're lying."
Like the way this guy
>> Yes. Exact. Yes, Ms. Keif. Exactly.
He is trying to raise concerns, raise doubts, doubt. Put doubt
on you, Ms. Kef. Yes, that is what he's doing. >> Trying
to denounce everything I'm saying >> and stuff like that.
Or there was enough reason to grant the protective order there.
Now, I'm no lawyer here to interpret what that means or to even
verify if that is accurate, but basically Miz is creaming himself
based on the >> So, you're not a lawyer. You don't know
what the [__] you're talking about and you're just
going to try to continue to attack me and and make the most unfunny
jokes you can ever imagine
>> did Misk see this guy do the Skyrim the Oblivion rather
NPC music when Misk was dancing or cool. >> Did Misk see
that part? Misk might lose it on that part. Okay. >> That
was not a good part. That was not good, man. >> Who? So
then he continues saying some stuff about a whiteboard and then
says that Techone tried to convince Amiu's parents that they
were dating.
>> Just wait, chat. Okay, but that's not true. You actually
would sit her down with a whiteboard and go over everything to
convince her that she was wrong. Why can't this guy just be like,
"Yo, this is pretty crazy stuff if this is true, but like uh
we'll wait and see. I don't believe Mskith because Misks are
and that's it." He could have just said >> I love I love
when streamers are like, "Hey, I have absolutely no qualification
to make an assessment here." >> Oh, wow. I do that sometimes.
>> Probably not in this case. I think >> I think
a lot of this stuff's pretty easy to understand,
>> Trying to like for the most part audience for techone
already. >> That's what he's doing. >> Failing to
see how this two connect, but I don't understand what you in
regard we we've talked about with the whiteboard >> I am
literally saying almost quotes in the courtroom by the way with
this. You would sit down with her at the whiteboard and whatever
position she was taking. You were all disagreeing in on correct.
If we were having an argument and not seeing eye to eye and we
weren't seeing eye to eye, visual aid really helped her as well
as to me. This dude would pull out a whiteboard to explain why
she is wrong about consensual
Are you kidding me? He would HAVE TO BRING OUT A WHITEBOARD and
say, "Oh, the reason why is because she doesn't understand it.
So, I have to visually show her and explain it. So we would have
a a conversation of non-consentual consensual on a whiteboard.
>> Techone one time went to Emy's house when her parents
were there and allegedly Tecton went to her parents house, sat
down while she wasn't there.
>> All right, we're going we're going really hard right
now. Jesus Christ. Going really hard on the techone stuff. I'm
about ready to switch over to the legal mindset [__]
We're going to >> and told >> I don't know if I need
like five minutes or so. I am quite excited for that. I do want
to see the the lady boy Mindset stuff. I want to watch the whole
thing. Um guys, uh last chance before if you want to be there
like early, okay? If you want to be there when we start right
off the bat, it takes a second to integrate your Discord account.
So again, it's patreon.com/jstalk.
All right. Well, I'll open it for all the Patreon tiers, but
if you want to hop in there. We're going to go over that legal
mindset stream. I I don't do a ton of Patreon content, okay?
Just risk it and do it on stream, please. I'm not risking anything.
I'm just not going to broadcast that.